let's get started
how's everyone doing come on let's do
better than that
how is everyone doing thank you
welcome to 309 one
this is the first day and i'm really
excited i hope you are too
um in this very first lecture we're
gonna do a little bit
of administration uh tell you a little
bit about the class and how it's set up
um and uh then we'll give a little mini
we'll have time for a mini lecture
uh in the second part of the lecture
today so i thought i'd start by
introducing me
uh my name is uh jeff grossman i am in
course
three that's the department of materials
science and engineering uh
my background i went to hopkins
undergrad
moved my way towards the west coast
illinois phd
and i did a postdoc at berkeley and then
i came
here to mit about nine years ago when i
joined the faculty
my own passion my own interest in
research
is in materials for energy
and water and chemical processes and
separations so i thought i'd just give
you a little example of what i mean by
that
so i get really excited about the
ability to take a material
and make it do something that it can't
do now
but that it needs to do to solve a
problem maybe it needs to be cheaper
maybe it needs to be more efficient
right um so one example is in this
material this is
a barrel of oil
and what we do today with this barrel of
oil is
we mostly burn it a lot of what we do is
we burn now if you do that you think
about in terms of energy
that's 159 liters of this material
and if you think about what you're
carrying about is energy you get 1.73
megawatt hours of energy out of that
um but see i like to think about
materials again and ask them what they
can do differently
for me for these problems and so if you
think about that and you say well okay
let's just take one percent of the
carbon in that barrel of oil
and do something with it let's make thin
film solar cells
right well if you do that and they're
not very good they're five percent
efficient they completely die in a year
you get ten thousand times as much
energy over that year than burning it
so it's an example of what you can do
when you think about using elements
differently
that's what i get really excited about
in my research
and that's just one example you can go
you can take that same carbon and you
can make a thermoelectric that's on top
or you can make the world's thinnest
filter that's a piece of graphene with a
hole in it
and that's still working with just one
element carbon
right so there are many many things you
can do once you understand
what these elements are and how they
combine together and that's what we're
going to talk about in this class
over the fall how many elements are in
your phone
list we just talked about one element
anybody know how many elements are in
your phone
how many take your guess seven
27. okay it depends
it depends do you have do you have the
samsung
if you if you got the samsung whatever
it might light on fire
if you got the newer one it won't do you
have an iphone
but you know what in the iphone there's
63 63 elements
right um so we have these lectures in
course three
they're called the wolf lectures and i
gave one a couple years ago if you're
interested in hearing a little bit more
about what i do or what
some other people do who think about
materials in this way you can just
google wolf lecture and you'll get to
some of the
uh some of the videos um and i'll
mention it when they come around during
the year
okay so that's a little intro to me
what about the class so as i said the
class at the heart of the class is kind
of what i just described
but in order to do that we need to know
some very basic things
we need to know how atoms
are arranged right the atomic
arrangement right there
we also need to know what atoms are
there in the first place so but if we
know that
if we know those things then we can
build then we can build
right we can get properties we can get
structure
we can get processing we can get
performance and we can talk about how
all of these things
relate to each other they're all
correlated if i change the processing of
something
i change the properties how do you know
how it changes
well you've got to know these things and
at the core of it all
is really the thesis of this class
which is that the electronic
structure the electronic
hall we'll be talking about this
structure
of the elements
holds the key to understanding
that really is what this class is about
holds the key the electronic structure
of the elements holds the key
that's what we're here to talk about and
the first part of this class is really
the basic foundations of chemistry right
now some of you may have seen some of
this before we're going to build these
elements we're going to talk about them
we're going to learn about the electrons
and the electronic structure but then
we're going to make solids
out of them and we're going to talk
about what those do and how the
chemistry relates
to the solids into the properties of
those solids right
now i want you to know again this is a
sort of ministry of introduction right
you are not alone on this journey on
this journey
you have many many resources and we are
here to help you
to help you learn this material and do
the best you can
right so first you have me
you have your ta let's talk about them
in a second you have laura i'll talk
where's laura oh we're going to talk
about laura in a second you have the
textbook and the internet i hear their
stuff on the internet
and you have each other and i really
want you to work
together thank you who said those that
was like that hit me right here
right in the first 10 minutes of class
so the the
textbook is april it's a really good
textbook
it's a really good textbook please use
it please
all right it's available here um notes
like i said will be posted on the same
day of each lecture i'll post whatever
you see
on this screen i will post all right
good
the goodie bag so the goodie bag is
another part of your homework
and these will be given out um nine
weeks right so sort of like the quizzes
right and
in each goodie bag which i'm gonna talk
about in a second there are things to do
there is this is a hands-on compliment
to
3091 lectures and
all the other materials now um
this uh uh these goodie bags are really
important
and one of the two quiz questions every
week that there's a quiz there are two
questions
and one of them will be directly related
to something that you're supposed to do
in the goodie bag and in fact
we will most times ask you to bring
something into the quiz
that is in the back so don't like throw
it away and
please do it because one of the two quiz
questions will be very related to the
goodie bag and the other will be related
to
uh problems you know lecture
everything's related to lecture
right but at least one will be related
to what's in the back so this we really
take this seriously this is a very
important part of your homework
and um oh there it is some of which you
need to bring to the quiz and we'll tell
you what that is
before the quiz i want to tell you a
thing though because
here's the thing when you know goody
bags are it's a little bit of
what's going on here it's a lecture
class why are we getting goodie bags
right um and it's because
i believe in the soul
of mit i believe in the soul of mit
and that is that we learn best
by thinking and doing by thinking and
doing
and even though this is a lecture class
i still want you to do i want you to
have stuff in your hands
so that you can play with the chemistry
that we're learning about
um now this goes back
i said the soul of mit what do i mean
this goes back
all the way back to before mit was born
1850s you got a group of really smart
people
they're getting together and they're
meeting and they're saying okay we're
going to start up a new university
what should we do and they wrote out a
plan
they wrote out a plan and it's called
the institute plan that makes sense
1860.
it's a great read and but i want to pull
out one part that's really important
that what they wanted to do with this
great new institution
was was to to do something
that would serve the interests of the
commerce and the arts
as well as of general education call for
the most earnest cooperation
of intelligent culture with industrial
pursuits intelligent culture
industrial pursuits that is
men's emanus that is men's imanus
right mind and hand
it's so important to mit that we put it
on our logo we put it on our logo that's
how important it is
we don't put some animal on our logo
we put what matters men's
emanus we don't put the word
truth
veritas veritas i mean i'm not gonna
name
names harvard
uh but i mean isn't that setting the bar
kind of low
like you know you
were they lying before
i don't know i'm not i look
honestly i don't know i don't know but
what i know is that what we know
is that of course the goal is truth the
difference is we know how to get it
men's imanus is how to get it let me ask
you a question
why are you here not
not here in this classroom i know you're
here in the classroom because you've
signed up for it
why are you at mit why are you here at
mit
right i can tell you you are here
because you are some of the brightest
most gifted most talented students on
the
planet right thank you whoever said that
agreement that was like a like online
the but you are here because you want to
use those talents
to make the world a better place right
you are here because you know how to
answer
any question but you are also here
because you are going to experience a
transition
you are going to experience a transition
here you are going to make the
transition
from knowing how to answer any question
to knowing which
question to ask and that is the
transition from student
to scholar that is mit that's men's and
manus
right now uh it's not
easy you don't come here nobody comes to
mit to phone it in
right if if universities were
restaurants this wouldn't be that fancy
one where you go in and you order
and then somebody cooks and brings you
your food this would be the one where we
all go back into the kitchen
and together we make the best meal we've
ever had
that's the mit way that's the mit way
and it's not about you don't you don't
roam the halls here
and you know bask in this reputation
and think of it as some privilege to be
here
because uh you are mit's reputation
freshmen raise your hand yeah
starting there's a few of you starting
today
you are mit's reputation starting today
it's on you so we don't we don't walk
around
these great halls and feel privileged we
feel responsibility
that's what it means to be here okay
all right good well now that we got that
all straightened out
let's move on that's the end of my
administrative stuff
and with the last 20-25 minutes
i want to do a little bit of
an introduction to chemistry and
i'm uh
i i'm not going to ever test you on
history
but i want to just kind of get our you
know get ourselves in the mood
by by going back right by going back so
i'm going to give you a little bit of
history here
in a few slides so
we are interested in solid state
chemistry because
chemistry is that essential ingredient
to understanding
the natural world and the solid state is
the link between that
and materials and engineering right
that is the link and so we'll talk a lot
about this
all the time ho ho come on out jerome
but where did chemistry begin okay now
hold on
uh i got a pen oh no i gotta okay
that's better i thought it was a pen um
where did it begin where did it begin
well people were mixing stuff a long
time ago but really and there's some
debate about this
you know the word chem itself you know
it may have come from chem the land of
kem which is
means sort of the rich soil in egypt or
maybe it came from kamiyah and greek
which meant sort of mixing and pouring
together
but the point is that what they were
doing was they were taking stuff
and making other stuff out of it
that dagger there is from ancient egypt
it's from around 3000 bc
and the way they made that was by taking
stuff from a meteor
it was iron and some nickel and some
other things but from a meteor so they
and they were able to make
a really really strong weapon out of it
they called those daggers from heaven
right but the point is that what
chemistry is about is it's about
how you mix these things and what are
you mixing
in the first place what was it that you
took out of the meteor
and why did it make that instead of that
how did i get that dagger
right that's really what this is about
and and so
if we go back to sort of the first
people who really started discussing
this
we start with plato and aristotle
and plato
plato um now so plato had this idea
probably some of you may have heard
see there's what is stuff made of what
is like
the essence of things they really
thought about this and they debated it
and you know plato well plato said
there's four things and some of you may
heard this there's earth
right there's fire
there's air and
there's water
and everything's made out of that right
now
you can see that's a little limiting
aristotle came along and said wait a
second hold on
if i look out into the stars they don't
seem to change much so there must be
something else that's not quote
earthly and corruptible
uh and he called that ether but anyway
the point is like that's hard
it's hard to kind of explain everything
with this how are you gonna build the
world out of the we can't even explain
the boston weather
with just these four with just those
four words
so it was limiting but then along came
these guys
democritus and luciferous who was his
teacher and democritus said
okay look there's something fundamental
so democritus he said look
i believe there's something more than
these four things
the mock
and he said there are these things
called atoms so he was an
atomist and adam is um is
indivisible indivisible that's the
meaning
atomos in greek it meant
indivisible adam
and they fought about this they thought
about this a lot and plato it said was
so upset
about democritus that he wanted all of
his books
burned that's a seri back in the day
that was a serious dis it would be like
if i blocked somebody on
instagram can i do that is that a thing
no
snapchat what i don't know i was right
see that's helped me i'm blocking you
burn your books seriously dissing each
other
democritus now it it really happened
quickly from there
a mere 2 000 years later
we get to modern chemistry why did it
take 2 000 years
it took two thousand years because we
were missing something so we had a lot
of alchemy
the thing about alchemy there are
actually some really interesting
discoveries in alchemy
but they always tied it to something
very non-rigorous
like oh this works because of the faces
of the moon
or the tides right and and so it really
needed some
rigorous way to study
what things were made of right what
things were made of
and that came oh
inevitable that that might happen here
we go
that came with the scientific method in
the 1600s and sir francis bacon
and and i think a lot of you have seen
the scientific method
but it was pivotal for chemistry it was
pivotal
because it allowed people to think about
this question of what stuff is made of
but using a rigorous approach
make an observation form a hypothesis do
an experiment
record and that's what people started
doing
that is what for example robert boyle
did one of the earlier ones
to think about things and talk about the
element they were all
going back to think of thinking about
these same issues
what are things made of an element can't
be broken down
into two or more substance uh simpler
substances
by chemical means so he was at that he
was going for that core
what is at the core oh and then you had
priestly
priestly discovered oxygen
and he did it by burning things he did
it by burning things
just mentioning that word makes me want
to put those on
and and so he really
he really studied combustion he studied
these reactions that were happening with
oxygen and
carbon containing matter it was
combustion
so he burned stuff he burned this he
burned that he burned that
and he said what happens when i do that
that was another way priestly
sorry boyle played with pressure and
volume right
pressure and volume relationships for
gases that was his way to try to get at
what things are made of
priestley wanted to blow stuff up
oh and he also worked with beer
he actually worked with beer and he
discovered that the same gas that comes
out of fermenting beer
is the gas that comes out of combusting
okay so you got a guy who's working on
lighting stuff on fire and beer
and and you can imagine maybe that
wasn't going to be a good day
at some point and what happened is
actually his experiments did
this is true they slowed down when he
fell into a vat of beer
during one of his experiments now
the thing is though that he studied
combustion and that makes me think about
combustion and and i
feel like oh i feel like
this is a good time for
my goodie bag which
is to illustrate a point oh thank you
jerome
that's going to some feed somewhere okay
now the thing is that when you go to a
restaurant and they have real candles i
get really happy about it we'll tell
candle stories later
in the term as well um and this is what
you're doing
you are lighting a candle on fire now
when you do that you see
here here's the thing you're actually
i don't want you to think about it as
lighting a candle i want you to now from
now on
think about it as lighting c25h52 and in
fact
if you go to a restaurant and you want
to ask them if they have real candles i
don't care if you're all with friends
or maybe you're on a date raise your
hand ask the waiter and say do you have
any c525hv
and see if they know see if they've
taken some chemistry
what you're doing is you're doing that
you're combusting that fuel
well see the whole world runs by
lighting things on fire
you could light propane on fire or
you could light hydrogen on fire that's
where
we said you know hands-on is a good way
to learn
so let's see what that's like there's
the candle which is tilting i'm watching
it
really oh okay
so or you could light hydrogen on fire
and if you do that this is what happens
right so okay let's do that again these
bubbles aren't
oh i should have kept this on there we
go
that's really really fun
but i'm going to stop oh i'm not going
to stop because you just turned it on
again now you're
you're coaxing me to do more oh these
are bigger bubbles
these are bigger bubbles let's see if
this gets a nice flame
oh thank you there we go
all right okay now
my goodie bag for today um
we run our world by doing this i mean
not by lighting hydrogen bubbles on fire
um but when you plug your phone in to
charge it
you're lighting a fire think about that
you might not feel it
oh you are no i'm sick i love that
reaction i love that reaction
you are lighting a fire it may not be
you but somebody else is down the street
at a power plant
this is how we run our world we burn
things and so this this this study of
combustion was extremely
important and it's going to be our first
reaction um
so what what's happening when you when
you light c25
h on fire what's happening is that
you're reacting you're doing remember
priestly discovered
h52 plus oxygen he discovered oxygen
and he also remember this comes off a
beer too
he also discovered these other gases
coming out
right and that's the chemical reaction
is it the chemical reaction it's not
done yet
it's not balanced it's not balanced
mass is being lost left and right not
okay
not okay so we must when we write down
things that happen in chemistry like a
reaction
we must find balance it's also important
in life
but it's very important in chemistry and
and so if you balance this
right you're going to put a 2 because
here's the deal and i'll talk about this
more in a sec
c c 25 h
52 plus anybody know how many o2s
38 whoever said that 38 is going to go
to 25 co2
plus 26 h2o
these are the kinds of things that are
perfect perfect to keep doing
exercises on through your problems
through your goodie bags in your
recitation
right these are exactly how did you do
that if you don't know
you will soon you'll get help practice
right i
know i know i wrote this down
i'm just testing you
because the two was supposed to go to
the propane one
because i wanted to write that one and i
got excited and i went
i went to that instead and that would be
1302
and that would be eight co2 and so on
10 h2o these are
balanced these are
balanced and balancing reactions is
important why because
it it balances the mass and it tells us
something else
once we count atoms you'll see we're
going to count atoms on friday
right but it's telling us that you can't
just lose stuff
you can't just lose stuff you got to
have the same oh and that by the way
is what lavoisier lavoisier
where's jerome oh yeah no
butane not propane it very well might
have been c4h10 yes
i believe that is butane thank you
uh oh jerome come back jerome helps the
class and he helps my french
le voisier no ah
okay not say it oh
okay i try but
now he said look you gotta conserve mass
you can't lose
you can't create or destroy matter when
you do chemistry
when you do this when you do this you
cannot create or destroy
matter okay
conservation of mass lavoisier
um it means that
if i you know you get a little more than
that so this is balancing
um but you also can think about
you know whether you have anything i
probably should blow that
whether whether you have anything
did you have too much too little did i
mix it just right so
like if you think let's take another
reaction just as an example if i mix
iron and
oxygen to make
ferric oxide oh not balanced
two three four
and i tell you for example that i've got
10 grams
of iron reacts
with let's see
so okay i'm going to give it to you a
different way i'm going to say that it
gives
you reacts with o2
to give 18.2
grams of fe2o3
this is an example from the textbook
then i know because of conservation of
mass from lebron
that 8.2 grams if
if this reacts fully
right if if iron reacts fully it all
goes away there's none left
then i must have if i got 18.2 grams of
ferric acid i must have reacted
8.2 grams of oxygen that's conservation
of mass
but there's another thing you can do
with this right
so so i must have
reacted 8.2
grams of oxygen but there's another
thing because if i'd started
you know if i started now
with 10 grams of o2
and 10 grams of iron
ah i'm gonna have excess
i know that i know that now i'm gonna
have excess and the thing
is that there's something that's
limiting here what's in excess
oxygen because i started with the same
amount of iron there's more
but that means that we've got another
term which is that iron
is the limiting reagent
you see that because now
i'm limited meaning this reaction goes
and goes and goes and
something runs out first that is the
limiting reagent
right and this was this was just done by
thinking about lavoisier's conservation
of math i ca
mass i can't create or destroy atoms in
a reaction
not in this class you take nuclear
somewhere else but not here
here we don't destroy or create matter
limiting reagent
balancing reactions very very
fundamental first
chemical concepts now
these guys were playing around with
stuff and
and really trying to figure out again
they're going back to democritus
what are these indivisible elements
atoms what are they and all these guys
were starting to mess with that once
they had the scientific mesh
method they were able to go very far
here's the velocity's list
33 elements and he tried to organize
them
and in some cases he he succeeded fairly
well
look at this this is a okay where's
jerome
this is a table
substances no not even close
but look simples simples
simple fundamental
atoms what are those things that we're
mixing together that we've been mixing
together for thousands of years
what is that thing i'm pulling out of
this ore
and making stuff out of and he was
trying to classify them using these
experiments
right um and so and and some of these
are actually really
uh uh were really good discoveries
i want you to experience this i want you
to go back to this time
and that is what the first goodie bag is
about
so what i've given you in this goody bag
is
the most accurate measuring device ever
created
and branded 3091
it's a ruler i've given you five metal
strips and i want you to pretend that
you don't know what these are
how do you find out you do nothing
with fire nothing
but i gave you vinegar
and you do lots of vinegar pour it on
them measure it weigh it look at it
shiny not shiny different color
densities
think about what the differences are
right
and i want to put you back in that time
and i want to make a point here
goody bags are not just about the
questions i ask i hope
that you think even beyond the goodie
bag so if you use that vinegar and one
of those things reacts
let's just suppose with the vinegar
then think about what that is and maybe
vinegar is a test maybe it's a test and
you can react
you can pour vinegar and make reactions
with other things maybe you should be
thinking about where that thing is
in the infinite corridor and the whole
infinite quarter should smell like
vinegar
but we won't tell president reif about
that
but that's what i mean maybe not the
infinite but you know explore
these are meant to be i want you to
really use these as an adventure
you know think about think outside the
box so you've got this
most accurate measuring device you've
got these strips a pipet
and you've got some gloves and that is
your first
your first goodie bag okay now the
the last thing that i'm gonna tell you
about is why this matters
and just like the goody bags when i
started teaching this class three years
ago i wanted to also
protect a certain fundamental
part of each lecture and i call it why
my why this matters moment
sometimes it goes on for more than a
moment
but i really really want every lecture
to connect what we just learned
to a big picture most of the time it's
some application or some
global challenge right
i want you to see those connections that
what you're learning is directly
relevant to some big thing
so my why this matters moment is a is
really related to these discoveries
themselves
okay please give me until 11 55. i will
always let you go on time 11 55 but
please don't start putting stuff away
because it's distracting to everybody
um so two and a half minutes
we name the age we live in often by the
element by the atom by the material
by the material that was most useful at
the time
the stone age the bronze age the iron
age
i would say we've moved through the
industrial age the age of plastics the
age of silicon
as a material scientist an engineer i
love this i love that you name
the age you live in by the material that
mattered
but i also love that we will never do
that again
ever and the reason is that we live in a
truly unique age now
a different age one in which we can put
atoms we can realize feynman's dream
and put atoms anywhere we want the
question
is not can we make it as much anymore as
it is
what should we make we live in the age
of atomic design
and that is really important i mentioned
the phone and the 63 elements
you know look this is called a
revolution
this is called this is called a
revolution
you went in 50 years from a dollar per
transistor
eight orders of magnitude cheaper in
2012
it became cheaper to print a transistor
on a chip than a character
in a newspaper that's a revolution but
that revolution
it started as a processing revolution
with one
really important element silicon and now
it's a materials revolution
with 63. it's a chemistry revolution
and the reason this matters so much what
are these things
is because so many of the problems that
we
face in this world today so many of the
global challenges
will rely on new chemistry
and on new materials those
are the bottlenecks those are the
bottlenecks in cost and efficiency and
processing
right in properties and those are the
kinds of things that we're going to be
talking about
all throughout the fall and that is our
construction set and we will build this
on friday so see you guys all on friday
you